hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the AI comp Division One
winner section it is Magnus Carlson
versus Hikaru Nakamura and this is the
third game of their match where uh
Hikaru really goes all out so the same
yeah because he lost the first game and
he almost won the second game but Magnus
defended well and in the end there was a
position where he car was up a queen but
Magnus had two Bishops for the queen and
I think also Magnus had like four points
Hikaru had three pawns and they both had
like 30 seconds on the clock they agreed
to a draw so obviously Hikaru was not
very happy with that one uh he uh tries
to really go for for a win here with the
black pieces which means that if he does
they equalize the match and um you know
it could get decided in game four but
also it means that if he loses uh then
the match is over so let's check it out
Magnus has the white pieces and he opens
with Knight to F3 so we start off with a
reti opening but it quickly transposes
into King's Indian defense as something
that
um Hikaru is not only famous for for but
also is probably in modern times the
strongest player to play such an opening
G6 with Pawn to E4 Bishop to G7 and pawn
to D for the king's Indian defenses on
the board and we have castles which is a
pretty standard move with Bishop to E2
the Orthodox
um uh variation also the uh the top move
against this line and now you will see
uh E5 is the main move here sometimes
Knight D7 is played but here we have
Knight to A6 not extremely rare it's the
third most popular move but again that
it has been played by some very strong
players uh rajaba plays in glitter and
plays that Joe Baba plays it
um so you know it's a good Square for
the Knight you will play C6 that will
hunt the C7 later on maybe term You'll
Play some like E5 the Knight can come to
E6 and it will be very strong or you
will give it up for the bishop here your
Pawn structure will get ruined but uh
White will lose the bishop pair so many
options so here we have Castles by
Magnus Ponte E5 and now Bishop to E3 we
have knighted the G4 going after the
bishop and the bishop to G5 attacking
hikaru's Queen with Queen 38 and now D
captures an E5 if you wait for E Captain
D4 then the E4 Pawn will be hanging so
Magnus captures with d captors and now
Queen to C1 supporting the dark Square
Bishop here also you will have uh maybe
if the Knight moves let's say you kick
the Knight back you can play Bishop to
H6 and it um you guys are probably
wondering why Bishop to C1 why not uh
sorry Queen to C1 why not Queen to D2
doesn't this make more sense you connect
the Rooks also the queen is nicely
supporting the bishop yes but then black
plays F6 and you don't have a retreat
Square for the bishop if you go E3 uh of
course the Knight will just capture it
if you go to H4 which you can it's not
as potent on H4 so Queen to C1 is a
known move and of course that's why
Magnus plays it so here we have H6 and
Bishop back to D2 and now King to H7 now
the Knight can also move as the H6 spawn
will be sufficiently defended and later
on you will have some stuff for a
support for Pawn to F5 so upon the C5
also upon sacrifice that has been played
before because if you capture it then
Knights the D5 is very annoying you
attack the C7 Pawn also the Knight is
hanging and also if you uh defend it
with Queen to C6 then you can play
Bishop to B for you
pin the Knight here and it's uh well not
not a fun position to play for for black
so Hikaru just plays Pawn to C6 uh and
now we have Bishop captures on E6 here
there are a couple of games that reach
this position uh H3 is an unmove but
Bishop captures an H on A6 is a new one
so now as of move 14 we have a
completely new game so let's see what
happened uh B captures an A6 we have
Pawn to H3 kicking back the Knight
Knight F6 and now Rook to D1 uh we have
Queen t7 putting pressure on the C5 pawn
and Bishop to E3 Magnus simply defends
it with Knight to E8 now he car prepares
Ponte air Pawn to F5 in the spirit of
the king's Indian defense and queen to
C2 now adding more support to the uh to
this diagonal uh we have Pawn to F5 and
E captures and F5 and while you could
capture with the bishop uh G captures uh
on F5 is more in the spirit of the
king's Indian defense and now you have
to worry about E4 you have to worry
about F4 and so on so Hikaru definitely
playing for the win here we have Rook
back D1 and now Queen to F7 you don't
have to worry about F4 for the moment as
the F1 is pin so Rook 8 D1 Magnus puts
uh both of his Rooks on very nice files
DND and Rook to G8 putting pressure on
the white king here we have Knight to E2
and now Bishop to E6 just continuing
development putting pressure on the A2
pawn and uh we have knighted the G3 by
Magnus uh putting some pressure on that
F5 Pawn so if the bishop captures you
might be interested in some Knight
captures an F5 action and also you still
don't have to worry about that form as
the pawn is spin so King to each eight
he current pins and now Magnus plays
Knights to H4 and uh you it looks like
you maybe can play this but if you play
the knights the G6 check and look at
this King H7 Knight to f8 opens up a
discovery and also its check from the
Knight king h8 and queen to H7 will be a
very nice Checkmate so after Knight H4
Rook to f8 uh clearing the G8 Square for
the black king but now the The Rook also
doesn't have all that much to do on f8
Magnus plays Bishop back to D2 you could
also play it the C1 uh but if if you
play the C1 then you will not be able to
shift it over to this diagonal and here
kikaru hikaru's position is not an easy
one to play but you could still play it
you always uh you know the engine always
says you're slightly worse when you're
playing the king's Indian but he has to
play Pawn to E4 or something like Rook
to did but he played Ponte F4 with the
idea that Knight the G6 check doesn't
really do anything as the Knight on G3
is hanging but not really Magnus just
plays Knight to G6 with check King to j8
and now of course Knight to H5 and The
Rook is lost here but okay uh Hikaru
obviously decided to give up the
exchange as he does have the bishop pair
like the bishop is coming the D5 should
be should be okay
so Bishop to h8 and the Magnus captures
The Rook Knight captures King captures
and now Pawn to G4 with f captures and
G3 and now Bishop captures an H6 with
check with King to G8 and now Knight
captures and G3 uh Bishop captures an A2
Hikaru even takes a moment to grab a
pawn but not really to grab a pawn he
wants to play Bishop to B3 to win some
material here so Queen to E4 now
Shifting the queen over to G4 with check
also the C6 Pawn is hanging and now
Bishop to D5 defending upon attacking
the queen queen to G4 check King to H7
and now Queen to H4 Magnus now threatens
all sorts of nasty discoveries here King
to G8 and now comes Knight to E4 also a
really awesome move is Rook to E4 but
this is rapid chess not a lot of time
for the players left and there is really
no good defense against the uh Rook to
G4 check if you block with Knight to F6
then the E5 Pawn is no longer defended
by the bishop here here and if your
character doesn't really help just
Knight captures and next Rook to D3 to
G3 is coming but similar uh uh maneuver
happened in the game night the E4 first
was played Queen to Eve F5 and now Rook
the D3 now Shifting The Rook to the king
side to help out with the attack Knight
the G7 and now Knight to F6 with check
King to F7 and now Knight captures on D5
so of course uh you could capture back
uh but then Rook captures on D5 so
Hikaru takes the Rook so a Magnus sort
of gave back the exchange but now comes
Queen to E7 with check the quickest way
is Queen to F6 with check I'm just gonna
show it because it's a lot of fun King
to G8 and now Knight D7 with checking H7
and now Bishop to E3 there's no defense
against Queen Tage six Checkmate um you
can only prolong the game with some
silly moves but we're not going to
actually show those so after this queen
t7 check by Magnus King to G6 and now
Queen to D6 with check
uh King to F7 and queen to D7 check and
it was in this position on move 41 that
Hikaru Nakamura resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here if
you go to G8 or G6 doesn't really matter
a simple Discovery from the night will
uh we knew the black queen on D3 and of
course if you go to f8 to avoid any
checks with the Knight then it's not a
problem just Queen E7 check King goes to
Jade and now Knight to F6 will be
Checkmate as the Knight also covers the
H7 Square so uh that's uh what happened
very nicely done by Magnus uh winning
game one and game three also means that
uh he won the match so it was a good
opportunity for Hikaru to exact his
revenge for losing his match to Magnus a
few days ago but as Magnus said before
the game revenge is a dish best served
not at all so there we have it uh that's
the game hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank uh Peter Peter purapu also
treat Helga mattress
festival.org.gg from 15 to 21st of
October 2023 for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up any wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and do use hashtag
suggestion if you have a favorite game
from this event see you soon